et c'est le moment de jeter un coup
d’œil à ces histoires qui sont restées
un peu dans l'ombre cette semaine avec
mes deux collaboratrices les
affectatrices parlementaires de
Radio-Canada Marie-Hélène Tremblay à
Québec Fanny Olivier Ottawa bon dimanche
à vous deux bonjour Fanny il y a le
leader du gouvernement en chambre
Marcelin qui a livré touchant témoignage
ma foi cette semaine dans le cadre d'un
comité parlementaire où il appelait pour
davantage de compassion en politique oui
c'était au comité de la procédure où les
élus se penchent actuellement sur la
pertinence de prolonger ou pas les
travaux parlementaires en formant
hybride et marque Hollande a donc parlé
en termes très personnel de l'importance
d'injecter davantage de compassion en
politique il a révélé au comité que
lorsqu'il a perdu son siège en 2011 il
s'est retrouvé devant un tel vide qu'il
a tenté de mettre fin à ses jours il a
expliqué qu'à l'époque son il avait tout
misé sur le travail sur son travail de
politicien au dépend de la sphère plus
personnelle de sa vie on peut l'écouter
alors quand il a été réélu 4 ans plus
tard il s'est dit qu'il voudrait faire
de la politique autrement alors selon
lui on doit tenter d'accommoder autant
que possible les députés et le personnel
politique pour rendre leur travail non
seulement plus productif mais les rendre
eux plus résilients il veut qu'on
injecte une bonne dose d'humanité dans
les communes et pour se faire il pense
que continuer de s'yé de façon hybride
c'est déjà un bon début son témoignage
Daniel c'est aussi un rappel qu'en
politique les défaites peuvent être
cruelles et que les députés tout comme
nous on leur propre vulnérabilité
cette semaine des ministres les
reconduits et les nouveaux se plongeait
dans leur cahier de bréhage il faut se
mettre un peu au courant des dossiers ça
nous donne l'occasion de parler d'un
nouveau programme universitaire en cyber
sécurité oui la sphère sécurité c'est un
phénomène qui préoccupe de plus en plus
autant les gouvernements que le secteur
privé on le voit les cy sont de plus en
plus fréquentes de plus en plus
nombreuses et les menaces de plus en
plus sophistiquées aussi alors comment
se prémunir contre ce phénomène et avoir
des ressources justement pour intervenir
quand une cyberata que survient
l'Université du Québec à Chicoutimi
espère faire partie de la solution
l'établissement universitaire vient de
s'associer avec deux entreprises
Desjardins et cyber Eco justement pour
offrir des programmes universitaires il
y a un programme de maîtrise donc qui
est offert depuis la rentrée d'automne
dans la prochaine année un programme de
certificat universitaire sera également
offert donc aux étudiants et on
aménagera un laboratoire où les
étudiants pourront justement mettre en
pratique tous les apprentissages qu'ils
auront reçus alors évidemment ce qu'on
souhaite c'est ainsi recruter faire
amener davantage de gens à s'intéresser
au secteur de l'informatique parce que
dans ce domaine comme dans bien d'autres
on le voit il y a une pénurie de main
d'oeuvre et on espère que ces programmes
universitaire donc viendront combler un
certain manque important dans cet
industrie c'est clairement un domaine
d'avenir c'est moi qu'on puisse dire
Marie-Hélène à Québec Fanny Ottawa merci
à vous deux au revoir au revoir